Despite the saturation of comic based stories
on screen, superhero fatigue has apparently
yet to set in with audiences, as Avengers:
Infinity War cleaned up at the box office
with a record breaking take.
But just because Earth's mightiest heroes
are still as popular as ever, that doesn't
mean they're all safe from elimination.
2018 has already proven to be pretty intense
when it comes to central characters biting
the dust, and already this year, we have a
large body count of superheroes stacking up.
"I hope they remember you."
Sure, a lot of them may be back sooner than
later, but for now, let's take a moment to
mourn those we've lost across the comics universe,
from the page to the small screen to the theater.
Spoilers ahead!
Clayface
It might not make sense at first to see the
name of one of Batman's signature villains
on a list of fallen superheroes, but Basil
Karlo had recently taken steps to change his
ways and make up for his many wrongs.
Batman was even attempting to recruit him
into the ranks of the Gotham Knights, but
toward the end of the Fall of the Batmen storyline,
Clayface went wild and smashed through Gotham,
destroying everything in his path.
While most of the team tried to find a non
lethal way to stop their budding teammate's
rampage, Batwoman was given a gun designed
to kill Clayface by her father Colonel Kane.
Detective Comics #973 ended with Batwoman
blasting Basil Karlo through the skull.
And just in case it wasn't clear that this
wasn't some cliffhanger, Dr. October confirmed
his death in the following issue, and Batwoman
was ejected from the Gotham Knights as a result
of her act.
The Mighty Thor and Mjolnir
For years, Jane Foster has been carrying the
mantle and weapon of Thor, but all that world
saving has been slowly but surely taking its
toll on her.
Foster was suffering from cancer when she
took up Mjolnir, and eventually, she learned
that every time she transformed into the hero,
she undid all of her chemotherapy treatment.
As more people in her life learned of this,
they grew more adamant that she stop turning
into Thor and let the rest of the world's
heroes do the heavy lifting.
When the Mangog was unleashed on Asgardia,
though, she had to step in.
In Mighty Thor #705, Thor used unbreakable
chains to wrap Mjolnir and Mangog, and hurled
the both of them into the Sun.
Mjolnir was destroyed, and Mangog was imprisoned.
Without Mjolnir, Thor reverted back to Jane
Foster and died.
Ultimately, the human version of herself would
survive thanks to some heavenly intervention,
but her version of Thor was done for, alongside
the trusty weapon.
Ghost Rider
Johnny Blaze went out in a blaze of intentional
glory during Marvel's mini event, Damnation.
Mephisto seized on an opportunity to try and
bring hell to Earth, by way of the City of
Sin, Las Vegas.
While Doctor Strange resisted the effort,
Wong cobbled together a makeshift Midnight
Sons team that included Johnny Blaze, Marvel's
original motorcycle riding Ghost Rider.
In Doctor Strange: Damnation #3, Blaze confronted
Mephisto, but unimpressed with his old enemy's
bravado, Mephisto snuffed out the flame of
Johnny's skull, lifting the Ghost Rider curse
from him.
Then, with Blaze's powers gone, Mephisto send
him to hell alongside his "dark passenger."
But with the throne unguarded, Blaze gathered
an assortment of D list supervillains to join
forces and stage a revolution to use the power
of the underworld to help Strange and his
other allies, proving that even death isn't
the end for some heroes.
Rip Hunter
In the season 3 finale of Legends of Tomorrow,
the time hopping team lost the guy who brought
them all together: the former Time Master
Rip Hunter.
Hunter perishes while trying to save his friends
from the demon Mallus by detonating a time
core to give the rest of the Legends time
to escape.
And while the explosion took Hunter out completely,
it only weakened his demonic enemy.
Hunter wasn't alone in meeting his fate in
the season finale.
The otherwise nefarious Damien Darhk sacrificed
himself to Mallus to save his daughter Nora.
Ralph Dibny
The Flash's villain Clifford DeVoe, a.k.a
the Thinker, has been racking up a large body
count in the show's fourth season by absorbing
the powers of Central City's metas.
Perhaps the most devastating loss of all is
Ralph Dibny, a.k.a. DC's Elongated Man.
Ralph had the misfortune to be standing next
to DeVoe after he was captured by Team Flash.
DeVoe freed himself, and used his powers on
Dibny, ending his life.
Is he gone for good?
Well, The Flash does have a tendency to bring
back the departed, so time will tell.
Heimdall
Avengers: Infinity War brought a lot of loss
to the Marvel Cinematic Universe, and the
first of its victims was one of the last Asgardians:
Heimdall.
After helping to rescue the Asgardians at
the end of Thor: Ragnarok, Heimdall is on
board the refugee ship when Thanos and his
Black Order attack.
Although he's already badly injured, Heimdall
uses the last of his strength to activate
the Bifrost and send the unconscious Hulk
to Earth, and it's a decision that costs him
his life, possibly forever.
Loki
Some fans might have trouble believing Loki
has finally met his maker for good this time,
considering he's "died" twice already in the
first two Thor films.
"I wish I could trust you."
But Infinity War might have actually brought
the God of Mischief down once and for all.
After Thanos and the Black Order board the
refugee ship, Loki initially seems unwilling
to give up the Tesseract.
Unwilling to watch his brother suffer at the
hands of Thanos, he gives in and gives the
bad guy what he wants.
Loki tricks everyone into thinking he wants
to join Thanos in his search for the remaining
Infinity Stones… until he lunges at Thanos,
dagger in hand.
He stops Loki's attack easily, and chokes
the life out of him.
Considering the countless innocents who died
at Loki's hands in the first Avengers, not
to mention the attempted genocide of his own
race, it could be argued that Loki's death
belongs nowhere near a list of fallen superheroes.
However, considering his actions at the end
of Ragnarok and beyond, while the guy might
not have been perfect, he clearly deserves
to be considered more than just a supervillain.
Gamora
Of all the death doled out by Thanos in Avengers:
Infinity War, the only one that he showed
any remorse for was the sacrifice of his adoptive
daughter Gamora.
Gamora is forced to reveal the location of
the Soul Stone to Thanos when he threatens
to continue torturing the imprisoned Nebula.
She leads Thanos to the planet Vormir, where
the two of them are met by the ghostly apparition
of the Red Skull.
The Skull explains to Thanos that in order
to gain the Soul Stone, he must sacrifice
that which he loves most.
Although Gamora thinks he's lost because she
believes he loves nothing, he tearfully throws
her over the rocky precipice, and we see her
corpse on the ground below before Thanos claims
his prize.
Vision
As a character whose very life presumably
depends upon keeping hold of one of the Infinity
Stones, the Vision is constantly threatened
with death in Avengers: Infinity War.
He comes dangerously close to getting taken
out the first time the Black Order attacks,
but he's saved by the timely intervention
of a few friendly heroes.
Once he learns of Thanos' plans, Vision insists
the only choice is to let Scarlet Witch use
her powers to destroy the Mind Stone.
Captain America brings the team to Wakanda
to see if Shuri can save Vision and the universe,
but once Thanos arrives in Wakanda, it's too
late.
Scarlet Witch destroys the Mind Stone, taking
out Vision in the process, but Thanos uses
the powers of the Time Stone to put Vision
and the Mind Stone back together, then rips
the stone from Vision's head, and leaving
him lifeless once again.
Ashes to ashes
If you're watching this, you already know
that Infinity War still ended with a very
dark cliffhanger.
One of the comics that heavily influenced
the movie was the 1991 mini series Infinity
Gauntlet.
In the source material, the story begins when
Thanos already has all six Infinity Gems,
and with a snap of his fingers, simply eliminates
half the sentient beings in the universe,
including a huge chunk of Earth's superhero
ranks.
Avengers: Infinity War saves this moment for
the end, and it's devastating not only to
the civilian populace of the universe, but
the ranks of the Avengers and their allies.
Needless to say, the Russo brothers' portrayal
of the event is much more horrific than the
source material.
In Infinity War, they feel what's coming before
it hits, and they're slowly erased, inch by
inch, until there's nothing left.
By the time the credits roll we see Bucky,
Black Panther, Scarlet Witch, Falcon, Drax,
Doctor Strange, Spider Man, Star Lord, Mantis,
Groot, Nick Fury, and Maria Hill all get erased
from the canvas of reality.
Considering that there are already confirmed
sequels in the works for Guardians of the
Galaxy, Black Panther, and Spider Man, it's
a safe bet that not all of these dusty deaths
will stick.
But if they do get reversed, it likely won't
be until next year's Avengers sequel, and
we won't know until then who will come back
and who won't.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!